bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi à 9 juin
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous allons revenir sur
votre actualité locale entouré de nos
invités mais également des journalistes
de la rédaction tout de suite on
commence avec les titres de cette
édition
ce n'était pas arrivé depuis près de 30
ans à l'appel des syndicats cfdt et unsa
des agents municipaux de la commune de
maurepas se sont mis en grève
ils protestent contre les conditions de
travail liée à une baisse des moyens et
un manque de personnel et le personnel
hospitalier des yvelines en colère
vendredi une grève est annoncée le
personnel de plusieurs hôpitaux du
département va se mobiliser devant la
préfecture de versailles contre la loi
santé de marisol touraine et les groupes
non hospitaliers des territoires nous en
parlerons ce soir en plateau avec
différents syndicats mobilisés et enfin
le grand jour c'est demain pour les fans
de l'euro les équipes sont arrivées en
france et ont commencé leur entraînement
focus sur l'irlande et la russie dont
les camps de base sont installés dans
les yvelines dans notre chronique avec
mickaël millero et pour commencer cette
information 782 commune dans seize
départements sont reconnues en état de
catastrophe naturelle après les
inondations et coulées de boue
historique qui se sont déroulés du 28
mai au 5 juin dernier alors l'arrêté
interministériel correspondant à une
première série de communes a été publié
au journal officiel
57 communes dans les yvelines en font
partie alors parmi elles il ya ben bois
d'arcy chevreuse ou dans l'ancien môle
maurepas le mesnil saint denis
monfort l'armory ou encore rambouillet
saint germain en laye son chant ou
vélizy alors l'arrêté ministériel sera
complétée pour tenir compte des communes
dans lesquelles la décrue n'est pas
encore achevée les particuliers et
entreprises disposent d'un délai de dix
jours à partir de cette date pour faire
leur déclaration de sinistre auprès de
leurs assurances les collectivités
territoriales ayant subi des dégâts pour
ont également touché des dotations de
solidarité des subventions qui vont de
30 à 60 % du montant total des dégâts
le fonds des de relogement d'urgence
sera également mobilisée
et pour les aider à assurer
l'hébergement provisoire des sinistrés
des outils sont également mises en place
par la préfecture pour soutenir les
entreprises industrielles commerciales
et agricoles
nous y reviendrons demain vendredi avec
une édition spéciale consacrée aux
intempéries et leurs conséquences
prenons à présent la direction de
maurepas ou à l'appel des syndicats cfdt
et unsa des agents municipaux de la
commune se sont mis en grève aujourd'hui
une première depuis une trentaine
d'années ils protestent contre les
conditions de travail liée à une baisse
est des moyens et un manque de personnel
mélanie potiche pour ce reportage
ils étaient près de 150 agents à s'être
rassemblés devant la mairie de manre pas
aujourd'hui le personnel municipal
répondait à l'appel des syndicats cfdt
et unsa
trop de souffrance au travail ça va pas
de part et d'autre de tous les agences
et c'est toujours la même chose qui
ressort c'est on n'a pas assez de
matériel pour travailler on n'a pas
assez de moyens humains pour travailler
si on aurait pu éviter voilà mais bon
malheureusement on en est là et c'est
dommage on est uniquement sur une
gestion financière et c'est un peu le
reproche qu'on fait je veux dire on peut
pas être assimilée effective
bon c'est le tract on est à un âge légal
un pion c'est ça je veux dire non on
n'est pas que des que un budget à la fin
de l'année en fait c'est ça le truc
c'est que cette gestion est laid que
financières ça manque d'humanité
très franchement le mouvement inhabituel
sur la commune est soutenu par les élus
de l'opposition se fait plus de 35 ans
qui en a pas eu de grève à l'appel des
agents de la mairie pour des affaires de
la mairie
il ya eu quand tu helmand des
participations à des grèves nationales
ça existait mais de mémoire d'élu je
n'ai jamais vu ça ça veut dire que qu'il
ya beaucoup de problèmes en interne
ce que l'on sait art par dae kim hong
kong entend ici ou là par des
indiscrétions puisque les gens ne
peuvent pas parler
c'est une situation qui dure depuis
plusieurs mois donc
pour pas dire presque un an nous avons
des témoignages d'un certain nombre
d'agents qui nous font part de leurs
difficultés humaines a travaillé depuis
quelques temps et ça ça nous touche
fortement en tant qu'être humain la
majorité elle souligne son
incompréhension devant le manque de
revendications et avance le contexte
national avec la baisse des dotations
aux collectivités de 2,4 millions
d'euros pour la commune je vais pas
m'étaler mais en tout cas nous avons
découvert des situations complexes que
nous traitons mais comme je les dis j'ai
mis en place depuis que je suis arrivé
responsabilité au moins une réunion par
trimestre avec les partenaires sociaux
ce qui n'existait pas avant
et j'ai moi-même vous souhaitez
également des rendez-vous direct dans
les services donc par service avec les
agents pour tout se dire elle les
représentants syndicaux ont été reçus
dans l'après midi par le maire grégory
gars restiez la commune emploie 600
agents dont 150 vacataires un tiers du
personnel étaient en grève aujourd'hui
selon les syndicats 1 car selon la
municipalité politique à présent les
réunions publiques pour les candidats de
la primaire à droite et du son qui vont
se dérouler en novembre 2016 se
multiplient hier mercredi soir c'était
au tour du comité de soutien d'un juppé
de se réunir à versailles une réunion
animée par fabienne keller sénatrice du
bas du bas rhin et porte-parole du
candidat
il était question a des impacts d'un
éventuel à bréxent it des nouvelles
politiques énergétiques mais également
des nouvelles formes de mobilité
écoutez là elle était au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude à la
politique énergétique comme la mobilité
c'est
le concept d'une société plus sobre
alain juppé s'est beaucoup engagé sur
ces thématiques environnementales de
transport bien sûr comme maire de
bordeaux donc c'est une politique
d'ensemble que nous sommes en train de
construire et ce qui est passionnant
c'est que dans les réunions beaucoup de
concitoyens ont une contribution très
concrète et c'est ainsi que nous sommes
en train de constituer ce les
principales propositions qui seront
publiées dans les prochaines semaines et
parlons en sécurité routière à présent
les opérations de prévention continue
dans le cadre de la quinzaine de la
sécurité routière dédié aux usagers
vulnérables
alors dans ce cadre le groupe thales
organisé mardi un forum un moyen de
parler des dangers de la route
omniprésent dans le cadre du risque
professionnel manon labat et camille
lambert des lunettes simule un état
d'ébriété un guidon vous plonge dans
l'univers d'un motard
il ne s'agit pas de jeux vidéo mais d'un
forum de prévention pour la sécurité
routière
c'était en test de freinage et on devait
évaluer la liste la vitesse à laquelle
on avait on avait eu l'impact bah c'est
pas mal parce qu'on se rend vraiment
compte de
l'impact et moi je pensais que c'était
beaucoup plus que ça mais en fin de
compte n'en sait que 7 km c'est
impressionnant
une perception de la vitesse et des
risques pas toujours conformes à la
réalité
un forum accessible aux 3000 salariés de
l'entreprise
l'objectif les sensibiliser aux dangers
de la route
c'est très très important c'est vraiment
dans notre analyse du risque
un élément primordial aujourd'hui notre
personnel on est quand même dans les
yvelines en parle très proche orientaux
énormément de gens se déplacent en
véhicule il faut vraiment que les
entreprises en prenne compte et
l'associent dans l'eure
leur démarche pédagogique auprès de leur
personnel une prévention particulière
cette année envers les deux roues et les
dangers causés par les stupéfiants un
thème choisi pour les ateliers mis en
place avec la police nationale
partenaire de l'opération depuis cinq
ans chaque année on vient et chaque
année on a des questions différentes et
on a un engouement pour ce forum que
nicolas met en place et donc c'est vrai
que c'est toujours plaisant de pouvoir
expliquer les nouvelles réglementations
parce qu'on a un public qui est très
attentif à ça aussi c'est important
un atelier annuel productif en 2015
l'entreprise thales n'a compté que deux
accidents de trajet une partie du
personnel de l'hôpital andré mignot est
en grève aujourd'hui jeudi 9 juin
comme vous allez le voir sur ces images
il était devant l'hôpital à l'occasion
d'un mouvement de grève lancé à
l'initiative des syndicats sud cgt les
manifestants protestent contre la
suppression de 161 postes en équivalents
à temps plein la génération de 12 heures
pour aller les équipes soignantes le
week-end et la révision du nombre
d'infirmières et d'aides-soignantes
voilà ce sont les bonnes images que nous
voyons ce qu'il considère comme une
dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail ils protestent également contre
la loi santé de marisol touraine tout
elle le personnel hospitalier grévistes
ont d'ailleurs prévu de se joindre pour
manifester vendredi à 11 heures devant
la préfecture de versailles ils
rallieront ensuite l'ensemble de l'
agence régionale de santé
et justement cette grève nous allons
continuer à en parler dans nos
entretiens nous recevons en plateau
valérie louis alors vous êtes avec avec
freddy brunel
porte-parole le bonsoir de
l'intersyndicale c'est ce qu'a fait si
vous pouvez un petit peu préciser votre
dock c'est une intersyndicale surtout
que les yvelines des différents
établissements des yvelines qui vont
être regroupées en deux groupement
hospitalier territoire d'accord et il ya
aussi des collectifs de défense des
différents hôpitaux groupement alors à
ma gauche il ya michel espinasse bonsoir
à vous vous êtes né en porte parole du
collectif de défense de l'hôpital de
rambouillet merci pour exactement une
des animateurs du collectif un des
animateurs du collectif très bien merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors vendredi le 10 juin vous appelait
également à la mobilisation à 11 heures
devant la préfecture donc deux
versailles c'est un appel intersyndical
concerne toutes les divines et contre la
loi touraine dite de modernisation de
notre système de santé c'est bien ça
c'est tout à fait ça qu'elles soient un
petit peu vos revendications par rapport
à ça à coup sûr qu'ils sont les
problèmes de cette voie par rapport à
votre travail
la loi touraine va instaurer un
regroupement
de l'ensemble des hôpitaux du territoire
par groupement sur les yvelines malien
avoir 2 1 on aurait en sud et c'est une
marche forcée vers les mutualisations
les transferts de services les
suppressions de services et pour nous
c'est un énorme danger pour les
personnels et pour les patients qui vont
se retrouver avec des délais de route
des délais de parcours pour accéder à un
service qui leur correspond
alors vous parliez des groupement
hospitalier de territoire pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas ces spin elle prévoit
un nouveau mode de coopération entre les
états primes 10 entre les établissements
publics et 200 à l'échelle d'un
territoire en quoi ça pose un problème
seront dûment de tout d'abord vous
faisait allusion tout à l'heure à la loi
à son thé et vos clés vos auditeurs et
spectateurs
sache que la loi tauren inclut une
diminution de 3 milliards d'euros du
budget des établissements hospitaliers
pour une utilisation
n'attendez moins 3 milliards d'euros
pour 2016 et 2017 alors que les budgets
de tous les hôpitaux publics de france
étaient dans le rouge
donc la loi touraine c'est ça d'abord et
pour quel ministre a annoncé à cette
occasion la mobilisation exceptionnelle
de 10 millions d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires en 2016 pour accompagner
justement l'alliance en écoute et je
n'ai pas cette information elle a
annoncé il ya quelques temps 4 millions
d'euros supplémentaires mais jusqu'en
2020 elle va être ministre encore non au
maximum donc ses successeurs auront tout
loisir de nad annuler ses engagements
en fait elles cassent l'hôpital public
est elle comme la grogne se développe
alors elle annonce tout de suite et
quelques mesures mais nous ne sommes pas
dupes la réalité concrète je pense à la
rambouillet l'hôpital enregistre 24 lits
hospitaliers qui ferme d une menace sur
le service d'analysés biologiques qui
pour une grande part être transférées
sur versailles des menaces sur le savez
le service de radiologie ne sait ce que
disait ma collègue
les gens vont être obligés d'aller à
versailles pour se soigner quand ils
seront des problèmes en fait on réclame
pas la lune
on réclame on est dans un bassin de vie
à rambouillet 250000 habitants
on réclame le maintien d'un hôpital
public
de qualité qui soit en capacité de
prendre en charge le besoin de 105
premiers qu'ils aient besoin d'une
mutualisation nommé on est un jeune dans
un nom d' épouvantable vous savez on
parle de la journée on parle de
mutualisation en réalité il faut
comprendre démantèlement on parle de
projets partagés projet médical partagé
en réalité seront des projets imposé par
les établissements les plus importés les
plus important c'est qu'il ya une
bataille sur les mots où on donne des
mots positifs pour un réalité cachée des
réalités qui sont beaucoup moins
positive
monsieur vrai pour l'épauler passion ça
va se traduire comment justement à 7
cette mutualisation abbas il fallait
rajouter à ce que disait michel et moi
je suis partie du collectif de défense
de l'hôpital de poissy saint germain en
laye donc la mobilisation demain il ya
également les collectifs et l'ensemble
des syndicats disent yvelines
tous les hôpitaux en grève c'est à noter
quand même et en fait il faut se dire
une chose c'est que la loi touraine la
mise en application des groupement
hospitalier de territoire les j'ai
acheté un espèce de gros mots que tout
le monde ne comprend pas d'ailleurs même
au sein des hôpitaux ne comprennent pas
toujours ce que ça veut dire et les
impacts que cela aura de toute façon
pour les malades
il y aura un impact puisque l'objet dé
j'ai acheté de leur mise en application
ces deux de dijon de mettre en place des
soins palliatifs s'il fallait faire
utiliser un terme hospitalier pour faire
face à la pénurie de personnel mais
gaulle est également pour faire face aux
baisses d'effectifs d'ores et déjà
annoncé donc madame touraine elle peut
dire ce qu'elle veut sans l'objectif
c'est de diminuer les effectifs des
hôpitaux publics en france il est d'ores
et déjà annoncée - vingt-deux mille
postes d'ici 2017
c'est assez impressionnant et l'impact
ladite maison sur les hôpitaux locaux de
proximité par exemple celui de
poissy-saint-germain laissé moins 150
postes donc notamment des postes ont par
un bide ico donc les ouvriers les aides
soignants les infirmières qui seront
impactées c'est ce qu'ont les postes qui
seront
supprimer la poste suprême appel à
d'autres sociétés pour venir en aide aux
mères des postes supprimés des débats
des départs à la retraite non remplacés
donc ces deux suppressions qui sont
lancés et d'ores et déjà aussi une
quinzaine de médecins
il faut savoir que je vais vous donner
un exemple concret les j'ai acheté au
thé mise en place avant leurs avants
avant le vote de la loi c'est assez
impressionnant avec ce gouvernement
c'est à dire que la démocratie ça suit 2
il s'assoit dessus c'est à dire que pour
l'hôpital de poissy saint germain en
laye d'ores et déjà en a fermé un
service de l'oncologie sur blanc quand
la transférer sur motta joli ça veut
dire l'impact depuis le 1er novembre
2015 c'est que les malades par des
malades non un bas nylon ils ont dix
doigts se déplace à 30 kilomètres mais
sont pas les seuls à se déplacer il ya
également l'ensemble de leurs familles
de leurs environnements qui doivent se
déplacer mais également les tout le
staff hospitalier les salariés de
l'hôpital qui doivent également suivre
le l'activité à notre exemple concret
est tout à fait concret mais qui dit
encadre déjà je te l'a bien entendu
votre votre exemple la ministre de la
santé met en avant le fait qu'il ya un
déficit qu'il faut bien réservé à
lorsque vous vous attendez du coup
qu'est ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement qu'est ce qui vous va faire
justement alors en même temps non mais
attendez un déficit on va faire des
efforts on va casser le service public
le gouvernement mais qui jamais ne
s'arrête de deux noeuds de ne pas
investir dans l'hôpital public
qu'ils arrêtent de supprimer les emplois
puisque un hôpital sans emploi sans
médecin sans sans les le personnel
paramédical ne peut pas fonctionner
comme il faut qui il suffit d'aller dans
le moindre service d'urgence sur les
yvelines vous rendez compte qu'il faut
passer plusieurs heures avant de pouvoir
passer
et là vous avez tout un équipe médicale
qui est fatigué fatigué car s'il vous
plaît madame madame
valérie lui du coup par rapport
justement donc à cette situation les
yvelines sont très touchées si vous
savez c'est une situation qui est
globale il ya d'autres régions en
ile-de-france notre département sont
tout en en paille revoir c'est tout le
territoire l'ensemble des établissements
de l'an de toute la france doit adhérer
un j'ai acheté et pour reprendre les
termes par rapport à l'absence de
démocratie à l'absence totale de mon nez
dans l'air 49 3 c'est à dire que tout ce
qui sera décidé par les j'ai acheté
devra être validé par la rs c'est à dire
que si si l'hôpital décidé support n'est
pas celui qui convient aux hôpitaux la
rs1 posera si la convention projet
médical partagé ne convient pas à des
hôpitaux l'air s imposera même la carte
elle était elle était elle était décrite
avant même que les hôpitaux et les leur
mot à dire
donc c'est une absence complète de
démocratie sanitaire
vous parlez comme en comble le déficit
mais comment combler le déficit de la
sécu c'est déjà en arrêtant d'exonérer
les cotisations sociales gère le budget
de la sécurité sociale c'est quand même
un débat en lui-même est de toucher à
l'hôpital comme le disait michel en ce
moment c'est des réductions drastiques
on est dans une austérité total au
niveau hospitalière il ya trois
milliards sur le talent de
responsabilité à faire d'économies d'ici
il ya des débats le lait la remise en
cause des accords rtt
il faut il faut faire des économies
point barre l'ensemble de la loi dit
axée sur le parcours du patient le
dossier informatique le dossier patient
informatisé
c'est d'ailleurs là dessus que des frais
que des crédits vont être mous les ché
c'est pour l'accompagnement ensuite
effectivement on aura des super dossier
patient informatisé
mais c'est pas pour réembaucher du monde
là où il en manque et c'est de toute
façon pour faire des économies et tous
les services comme un administratif
logistique technique toute la communauté
hospitalière saute en éclats et tous les
services qu'on appelle doublons il faut
le faire de sérieuses alors je leur
avais montre
mobilisés donc le vendredi 10 juin les
organisations syndicales appellent donc
avec le collectif de défense et
développement du centre hospitalier de
rambouillet le collectif de défense du
centre hospitalier de mantes-la-jolie et
du collectif de défense de l'hôpital
public 2.6 saint germain à une grande
manifestation ce sera vendredi 10 juin à
11 heures à la préfecture de versailles
nous reviendrons sur le sujet merci
beaucoup à vous trois est revenue en
plateau fin et santé toujours depuis un
mois il n'est plus nécessaire d'attendre
des semaines à elancourt pour prendre un
rendez vous avec un ostéopathe le
quartier de la clé saint pierre elle
encourt accueille depuis le mois de mai
un centre d'ostéopathie d'urgence un
nouveau cabinet pour répondre aux
difficultés des patients à avoir des
rendez vous rapidement les quatre
ostéopathes sont liège à une prise en
charge dans les 48 heures camille
lambert vous présente les lieux regarder
obtenir un rendez vous avec un
ostéopathe en 48 heures c'est
l'engagement de ce nouveau cabinet
installé à elancourt
ils sont quatre professionnels à
proposer cette prise en charge dans le
cadre d'une urgence une nécessité pour
marquer ma soto et ses patients qui
devait attendre parfois plusieurs
semaines
ça permet une réponse supplémentaire à
une demande de soin soulager le patient
rapidement pour éviter que la pathologie
s'installe et que d'autres zones du
corps soient impactés soit en
dysfonctionnement
cette ancienne maison médicale à
l'abandon a été entièrement rénové un
chantier financé personnellement par les
six associés du projet trois mois de
travaux cinq salles de soins et une
décoration épurée
ouvert depuis le mois de mai le nouveau
cabinet fait déjà l'unanimité
on a ici un cadre où on est vraiment au
calme un cadre un peu privilégié des
locaux tout neufs
et on a des plus grandes salles avec
plus d espace donc pour les patients je
pense que l'accueil est meilleur
dès qu'on a un blocage le matin c'est
vrai que quand on appelle directement au
centre on a un rendez vous rapidement
dans la journée et c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment l'idéal en fait pour ceux qui
travaillent et ceux qui travaillent pas
aussi c'est très propre
c'est très clair c'est très zen très
calme surtout et quand on est en soi ça
c'est vraiment appréciable
l'ostéopathie est une médecine reconnu
par l'état comme une profession à part
entière depuis 2002 en dehors des
urgences le cabinet fonctionne aussi sur
rendez vous plus classique de 9h à 20h30
en semaine
nomiya présent l' agence de notation
standard and poor's vient de relever la
note de la communauté grecque
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines de la note de référence à long
terme passe de a+ à a - et celle à court
terme est relevé à a moins plu ce
contrat - le relèvement des notes
traduit notre anticipation d'une baisse
continue et structurelle de
l'endettement consolidé de la casse qui
à l'horizon à 2018 nous anticipons que
les performances budgétaires
continueront d'être très forte indique
ya notamment l' agence de notation
américaine pour expliquer sa décision et
nous recevons à présent sur ce plateau
notre journaliste sportif c'est mickaël
mille euros pour sa chronique sport du
jeu dit bonsoir à michael assure johan
ravi de retrouver pour cette chronique
est là je dis merci est ce que vous
allez bien je pense que oui parce que du
coup l'on rapproche je sais que vous
êtes tout excité plus content
effectivement floral je ne peux rien
vous cacher tout le monde en parle le
championnat d'europe de football débute
ce vendredi 10 juin avec le match france
roumanie au stade de france c'est
d'ailleurs le thème de ma chronique
aujourd'hui forum surprise mickael on
s'y attendait pas on s'y attendait part
effectivement deux équipes étrangères en
pour qu'en base les yvelines pour cette
édition 2016 l'irlande est à versailles
et la russie et à croissy-sur-seine
aujourd'hui les irlandais se sont
entraînés au stade mont boron de
versailles devant plus de mille
supporters déchaînés les enfants des
écoles avoisinantes ont pu assister à un
mini match entre l'équipe des
remplaçants les titulaires l'irlande
magna a pris dans les yvelines
on écoute un supporter alors comme on
disait à quand on disait ça fait du bien
de voir une autre équipe jouer que que
l'équipe de france ça serait je suis
habitué plus à aller voir les joueurs de
l'équipe de france jouer donc là de voir
l'équipe d'irlande ça fait plaisir
vraiment ça fait plaisir plus en plus
bonne ambiance avec les enfants le
public ans c'était génial les supporters
eux conclut mickaël ça fait plaisir à
voir
et j'aurai les rangs des irlandais est
également conquis ils ont trouvé la
pelouse de 24 mm normes uefa et les
installations au parfaite en écoute le
défenseur irlandais stéphane world
c'est un bel endroit pour s'entraîner on
ya fait une bonne session et on pourra
donner le meilleur
vraiment une chance pour l'euro face à
nos bleus non on va voir en face à nos
bleus peut-être pas mais en tout cas
dans ce groupe là on ne sait pas on
regarde le groupe de l'équipe tout de
suite ils affronteront la belgique 2
eden hazard l'italie et la suède de
zlatan ibrahimovic
l'ancien à parisien autant vous dire que
la tâche s'annonce compliquée pour les
irlandais vous ne trouvez pas florane le
groupe paraît compliqué donc la porte
entre la belgique et l'italie je pense
qu'à mon avis ça doit vraiment compliqué
pour s en sortir mais bon les joueurs et
les supporters y croient quand même oui
je pense parce qu'il ya une forte chance
que le troisième les 3e équipe avance
donc eh oui je crois que quelqu'un aura
l'opportunité pour le cap
non pas du tout pas du tout on est déjà
on est on est déjà été joué trois fois
contre le souhait des platanes on l'a
parfaitement maîtrisée n'utiliser
probablement les deux nous allons tenter
de donner le meilleur de nous mêmes et
je pense que les autres équipes vont
tout donner et etc tenter d'accéder au
prochain tour de la compétition
mais toutes les équipes dans notre
groupe toutes les équipes de la
compétition vont tenter d'accomplir leur
objectif la victoire finale sont
optimistes comme on dit l'espoir fait
vivre
voilà il faut floral en tout cas comme
l'a rappelé aux supporters les meilleurs
troisièmes seront qualifiés pour en
dehors des phases de poule i pour
accéder aux huitièmes de finale donc
rien n'est perdu même si la belgique je
pense que la belgique dans ce groupe
quand même leur crée des soucis en tout
cas on leur souhaite comme ça on ne
rencontrera ni les belges en italie et
pour nous c'est mieux on passe
maintenant à l'équipe de la russie siens
moins médiatique l'équipe de la russie
s'est entraîné au stade omnisport de
croissy sur seine devant plus d'une
centaine de supporters venus notamment
du club de football local les joueurs
ont réalisé une petite opposition ils
ont été également signé des autographes
on écoute les supporters les joueurs
mais des joueurs très forts
tu faisais beaucoup de base et qui
marquait bien les buts ça me fait
plaisir que nous cessons nationale
viennent s'entraîner dans ma ville et
sur le terrain où j'ai joué tout va dire
que tu es ce manhwa ouais ça me fait
plaisir de voir des pros dans ma vie loi
les russes sont loin d'être favoris dans
leur groupe l'amicale modèle favori mais
le groupe mkg pousser mais le groupe est
quand même plus équilibré que pour le
groupe de l'irlande les russes
affronteront l'angleterre comme on peut
le voir de wayne rooney au vélodrome de
marseille le match aura clairement
compliqué ce premier match au vélodrome
mais ça sera plus jouable contre le pays
de galles de gareth bale et la slovaquie
du napolitain marek hamsik je sais que
vous êtes fan de ce joueur
particulièrement je pense qu'ils peuvent
être une des surprises de l'euro avec
leur gardien et hakim vf
regardez le en images regardez comment
il s'entraîne florane une chute
galipettes frappe la balle voilà il se
pend main de leur gardien actuellement
va nous donner des belles 17 euros
effectivement merci à beaucoup michael
où vous retrouverez leurs dents si on
parlait sport de quoi allez vous nous
parler un petit teasing en quelques
secondes tout à son l'émission
l'émission été pré-enregistrées on a
déjà eu quatre chroniqueurs cinq
chroniqueurs en plateau qui était chaud
bouillant on a parlé notamment du basket
avec notamment longtemps tôt le chesnay
versailles qui a remporté le championnat
de france de nationale 3 lise accéderont
donc en nationale 2 l'année prochaine et
nous parlons également de la coupe des
yvelines maurepas a triomphé de limay en
finale 2 2 et puis ensuite tirs au but
eh bien merci à michel on a hâte de voir
ça une dernière information avant de
refermer ce journal c'était pour la
troisième année les architectes en
france ouvrait les portes de leurs
agents soient là la rencontre du public
te rend 2 durant deux jours cette année
c'était le week-end dernier
certaines d'entre elles s'étaient donné
rendez-vous à maurepas proposer des
ateliers aux enfants on les
foot a tout de suite prend sujet
effectivement qui les titillent ce sont
toujours les questions d'environnement
évidemment et puis et puis le prix de la
construction qui revient aussi souvent
en ce moment on a plutôt une une
tendance
se soucier de l'écologie ou en tout cas
de l'environnement et donc c'est
toujours ces questions là qui reviennent
les balades sont organisées
suivi par un architecte en général et
ont effectivement on leur présente les
différents projets l architecture
l'histoire la mort pas ils sont passés
la balade est passé au travers de
différentes de différents logements des
années 70 donc on apprend un petit peu
l'histoire l'évolution il ya certains
équipements aussi qui ont été visités
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous retrouve lundi
pour une nouvelle édition du journal je
vous souhaite donc une excellente soirée
et un très bon week-end et surtout allez
les bleus